what's up y'all I'm Bree green here in
Houston Texas at the weekly Family YMCA
we've got a huge surprise for him let's
go check it out
I'm here with Tyler he's a Youth and
Family director here at the weekly
Family YMCA how important do you think
it is to have good equipment here at the
YMCA oh huge basketballs Nets rims all
that goes into the atmosphere that we
create and it's such a huge part to be
able to offer that great experience
hey everyone I'm Neko gumake and I'm
here to help Bree for a special surprise
for the weekly Family YMCA
[Applause]
so on behalf of the National Guard we
wanted to present some new basketball
equipment in honor of your service to
the community
[Applause]
[Music]